how can we calculate the square root of
any four digit number without using a
calculator
in this video we'll see a special case
in which the number is a perfect square
let's see firstly we have to know the
simple squares of numbers from 1 to 10.
one thing you can observe here is that
the units digits one and one four and
four six and six nine and nine are the
same so let's try the square root of one
two two five the square root of any four
digit number will always be two digits
long
first let us divide it into groups from
the right to the left
we take two digits from the right that's
25 and what's remaining is 12. firstly
we need to see between which two perfect
squares does 12 lie if you observe the
table 12 is between 9 and 16. it means
it is between 3 and 4
so the answer to the 10th digit will be
3 which is the lower one
what will the unit digit be the ending
of this number is 5 so we know that the
units digit will be 5 so you get the
answer as 35 using the same trick can
you solve for the square root of 6 2 4 1
share your answers in the comments
section we'll see the solution in the
next part
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below